This is the flag of Earth, designed
by Oskar Pernefeldt of Sweden.
Just imagine with me for a second:
What if we celebrated our humanity
as much if not more than we
celebrate our nationalities?
As we become a spacefaring civilization
and we go off into the stars,
what do our nations mean anyway
when you're standing on the surface
of Mars or any other planet?
And then of course, back here on Earth,
as our planet is facing a climate crisis,
as our climate could be unlivable in our
children or grandchildren's lifetime,
I believe we need a strong symbol,
a flag,
to unite us to fight,
not just as nations, but as a species.
Thank you.